the annual bowl for the gold fundraiser  is coming up takes place next month  hosted by special olympics nevada the  event raises money for local programs  that help special needs athletes go  beyond sports  we are also in schools with our  championship schools and unified program  and we're in school districts across the  state  we also have healthy athletes which we  offer wellness nutrition and health  screening preventative health screenings  we also have athlete leadership programs  bowl for the gold mark your calendar  august 20th at sunset station our own  john langler will be emceeing you can  register on our website 8newsnow.com